Pizza could be an aphrodisiac if you
banged after eating pizza once all the
time I bang after eating I think sharper
is erotic
I don't think aphrodisiacs are real
except maybe green M&M pizza chocolate
chip cookies oh you know it is an
aphrodisiac much does this mean that you
just get horny at every picnic like
that's such a I need more of it but keep
your clothes on you know it's juicy it's
red after each one I'm just gonna yell
do you have a boner I can't really see
myself being turned on my avocado oh
this sucks fun
no not really I mean maybe it might turn
some people on because this is in the
middle of anime my card ball doesn't
work for me not a turn-on mm-hmm you're
a boner
yeah I'm not feeling anything there's
really nothing about this that I could
see as relate to anything whatsoever
yeah yeah is kind of a turn-on a banana
this idea that this is like a phallic
object and then you just fight out of it
even a banana will always look sexual
bananas make me gassy as met attorney
chocolate is better than sex it's the
texture of it when you break it it could
probably slide into the bedroom with
some chocolate if you're turned off by
it then I would I just interpret or not
buy it much you have some more oh sure
opening them and slurping them and all
that sort of thing it's sort of supposed
to be like a sexy kind of thing sexy huh
mm-hmm
all the operatives yeah yeah ruin that
it gives you sort of a freer aisle
situation sometimes it would be turn on
if I went on a date and someone ordered
the food as like the appetizer then I'm
then I'm like because he paid for them
I don't think aphrodisiacs are real but
I think there are sense memories tied to
certain things I changed my mind I do
think that yeah you combine this have
some oysters maybe some chocolate a
banana a banana and then you put it in
avocado
you're gonna be thinking three days
you're gonna need a lot of condoms
yeah the bananas booties the chocolate
is the is the for plan and the wine